why do you keep going with all three  like I feel like even a lot of great  entrepreneurs in that situation would  have been like I've already sunk  everything I have in these companies and  I gotta pick one  but you didn't I mean you kept doing all  three why yeah that was a very tough  call at the end of 2008 that was you  know one of the toughest goals I've had  to make because I could either Reserve  capital for one company or the other  unfortunately so the city didn't need a  ton of capitals they were okay between  SpaceX and Tesla you know it's sort of  like like you've got two kids and what  do you do do you spend all your money  just to maximize the quality the success  of one or do try to keep Earth left  unfortunately it worked